yes dennis quaid welcome to the show a
little sit down good to see you man good
to see you how's everything going uh
it's a rainy day out there as it is it
is it's terrible you got caught in
traffic but not in my heart good good
it's been bad around here too cuz
Trump's uh he's on 59th they think so
this whole Midtown area has been kind of
yes awful they were showing in the paper
is literally when he's in town now they
have to shut down the entire block for
security yeah it's gridlocked it's
ridiculous well so welcome to New York
thank you very much
are you your la-based I would assume yes
I lived here in the pre AIDS 80s Oh 185
with AIDS what chased you out of here
[Laughter]
I would imagine how much has the
industry changed because you've you've
seen a couple of different eras now is
it still a good time like when you look
at the young people coming in now are
you like you guys don't know what fun is
well what is going on in television
right now is very exciting because
there's good stuff being made yes yes
it's were independent films have have
gone and it reminds me of what was going
on in movies back in the 70s were you
felt like the inmates had taken over the
asylum huh and you didn't know what was
going to happen well there's a lot of
guys that he was always frowned on for
like really major film actors to go to
TV now DeNiro just signed on I mean
think this is like eight hundred fifty
thousand episodes to do this Amazon
series and there's a bunch of like legit
guys like yourself you're doing
something like that probably ten years
ago never would have done a TV sir oh
absolutely well the subject manner and
you know it started with the writers and
of course the directors were coming in
doing the actress of course followed and
the studio's there making what they used
to make 40 films each a year now there
may be making eight to twelve and you
have to be two hundred million dollars
out of a comic book
yeah and so this is the place to be yeah
Udrih and you've done the big moat you
did the GI Joe movie right you
so you've been in that world ad yeah day
after tomorrow
yeah yeah I don't mind being in that
world it's fun hanging on the right
piece but it's the subject matter and
everything that's around and it's it's
great let's talk about Bill for a second
I want to ask you about Bill how was
Mickey Rooney on the set make it work
you know I've heard mixed reviews about
much all I'm asking I he's he was
fantastic I mean he was a legend forgots
for God's sakes and we were we were like
together like every every day he was a
very old-school movie star and that's
the way he lived his life what he wanted
to hang out like off the set or just on
this earth no he went home in fact he
was actually doing a musical at the time
at night he was shouting during the day
and doing a musical at night Wow yeah
see I've heard that easy Yeller and
stuff like that and then you oh yeah
sure yeah but that's just as normal
that's just the volume he speaks that
and then we go from there you know what
movie were talking about before you came
in and I wasn't even I I for some reason
this movie I watched it probably twice
in a row all the way through because I
don't know it hit me for some reason
like a month ago I had never heard of it
and then I watched it and it was
everybody's all-american oh yeah do you
remember that movie yes I mean it was
just there was something about that
movie that it doesn't they don't make
movies like that anymore where it was
kind of I was telling Jim there was no
like super happy ending there wasn't
this tragic sad ending it was just a
movie about how life kicks the [ __ ] out
of you sometimes
hmm and you just press on all right and
they don't do that anymore like you
don't really see that anymore
somewhere one of those kind of ambiguous
endings yeah yeah everybody's always
looking for the ending but I I think
that was a novel before it was a report
was a film and yeah it's a I think it's
a really good story of athletes about
what what they're with what happens
after cuz you're this big star right
like College
college football go to the NFL this big
big thing and then before you're 40 you
know and this goes for any athlete
you're done and then there's the other
half of your life that you got to figure
out yeah what do you do you better in
locker room since you were maybe nine
years old yeah yeah I got hit with a
pitch when I was eleven that ended my
base I wanted to be a big star
maybe yes did you question when you were
doing that movie how the directors
producers whoever they were we're gonna
make you and Jessica Lange into like
high school college students and then
travel through the ages you know what I
mean
of course of course I was playing I was
playing high school students it was
about 28
she was right at the time we just looked
her up on IMDB Boise but yeah play nice
yeah well she was great she was really
fantastic you know
gonna get all the camera a little bit
smoky eye in a few years know that'll be
like they won't have to age with makeup
and they'll be able to do that like
perfectly well they had to do CGI
because now everything's HD so you can't
really gel the camera over anymore right
right right you want that grain in there
yeah it's helpful how was it playing
Bill Clinton it was a quite a time
that's good you guys bought it because I
don't know like have you heard I don't
know if you know Jim Norton from outside
the show but he does a bill back as well
I don't know I know you doesn't like to
be put on the spot but it's like oh
really you want to do Durling you seem
like sometimes you'd be more even keel
there no probably is also usually goes
back to one confidence that's one one
part of bills yeah in life yeah so do
you feel when you do somebody that
famous
it's hard it's a guy should play Nixon
it's like one of those things that
everyone knows do they sound like so you
do Clinton like and you want to do them
just how did you want to portray him it
was conversational you know it's uh it
was a piece called a special
relationship we differ HBO and and is
about his relationship with Tony Blair
and so you don't want to do like an
impersonation right yeah and Tony Blair
was uh Martin Sheen yes so I meant you
know I didn't do any kind of like makeup
that was gonna radically changed my face
other than you know hair color so you
didn't you just kind of played the the
guy maybe do the voice a little bit but
it's hard to do so you're an
impressionist it's hard to do a perfect
yeah that it's like a depression I don't
know I don't know where that line is you
just kind of get up there and you just
do the scene basically you don't shower
line you'll learn it and you forget it
you know just you don't think about it
shout the line and try to mention
pop-culture references that is an
approach yes I do a great film people
have been telling me I do it all the
time they go crazy for it they did I got
a call the other day like Jim Bill
Clinton in studio with you it's like you
don't have to do the pop culture stuff
Bill Clinton doing breakfast guy I'm
sorry though just yells it's very hard
of hearing that's very very good
you are Todd you were open to I like the
fact you're open about the fact that you
had a cocaine addiction and you talked
about all that stuff yeah and didn't
hide it which was kind of nice and well
I came out of the seventies I mean you
know ladies it was kind of in the budget
yeah yeah I had a white light experience
when it was 36 you know saw myself maybe
no dead or losing everything when I was
about time I was in five years and so I
did by 28 days and I was that yeah do
you say kids back then you could do
stuff you could just bring coke or
whatever on the set and there was no
social media there's no one to snitch
and go tell TMZ there's just like a
different way to do it where everybody
wouldn't find out immediately yeah it
was like it was it newsworthy because it
was like yeah you can't use foreign
shoes to like it wasn't it wasn't
anything but yeah
it's a you need to go through different
things in life and it was one of them
and you show by the way promoting quotes
called the art of more it's season two
is gonna be released on crackle tomorrow
yes so the entire season comes out at
the same time
yes alternate episodes come out tomorrow
and it's free that's the great thing
about crackles it's that free and you
don't need a subscription and all this
big huge signup thing you just you
didn't Google crackle on any device and
you can go right to it and start
watching it on any device do you like
that are all coming out at the same time
Amazon kind I think I'm sorry Netflix
kind of started that where this the
here's the whole season and I think
people it gets them a lot more
interested in the show yeah it's a been
watching binge watching what we call it
I guess right and yeah it's just being
able to watch something over a long
period of time I love doing that because
once I get committed and into a show I
really don't like waiting waiting around
no right then isn't it weird to like
used to like usually you saw somebody
once on TV years ago and you just didn't
see it again until they got it again and
give me ten years before you saw it like
to rerun six months later yeah yeah yeah
it killed the rerun industry like you
can't do really reruns anymore because
everybody it's either on-demand or
whatever everybody's got access to it
there is no value to playing the episode
again yeah when you get the what you
were talking about you know making
content and stuff when this comes your
way
at first the show the art of more do you
just look at the script angle I like the
script I'm gonna do it or do you go
what' crackle I don't understand I don't
know if I should be involved in an
internet thing before you know like is
there is that part of the
decision-making well there's certain
questions to be answered but really the
the main thing is they sent me the
script I read the script I get involved
in it yeah I really like the character
that's the first thing is it a good
story plus they also besides the first
script they also had the entire season
mapped out about what the story was
going to be of the characters and and so
there was an arc there which I really
liked and I just had a foray into into
television when CBS with Vegas and you
know it just turned out to be a
procedural despite all the talk the
right of what it was going to be right
it was it was a procedural
you know and which I wasn't really
interested in and and so then also like
crackle being a part of this really kind
of new platform I didn't I mean
certainly Netflix and Amazon and and
those venues are around but crackle
being free and the way being able to so
easily access it was very appealing to
me to sort of build a network along with
building a show yeah and it's the same
place that Seinfeld does his show on so
it's not like it's this they don't have
anything they got a lot of stuff gone
sorry well weird their first one-hour
drama and so that was it's a big deal
for like this yeah you have a pilot's
license - I'm pretty fascinated by guys
who decide to do that first fly yeah I
was I was really afraid to fly what I
first started but I got the right stuff
it was what got me um I was gonna play
an astronaut you know one of the first
and they all flew so I figured I had to
do it yeah I should learn how to do it
well yeah you like a real method actor
well I just like the research of it you
know going on all those doors I see
authorized personnel only and sort of
like getting to live all these kind of
lives or getting a real taste of it and
it's that's what it's been very exciting
for me so you you can fly a Cessna
you own I could buy I could fly Citation
Jets all the way up to that what
citations I mean I had well it's a job
it's got you know two inboard engines on
it seats about eight P fly in the fog
instrument they said that was genius
problem because he wasn't again I
actually flew the night before up there
in Long Island
Wow it was they were calling it VFR
which is visual flight rules but you
could look down and you could see the
fog on the ground and see the lights
coming up from but if you got out over
the sound it was an inkwell you know
you're black it's just black out there
and and it messes with your interview
so do you start like when you when
you're flying like that if you if
somebody's happen to the plane can you
not always tell
you're headed down no you can't you're
in fact you have a little airplane right
in front of you that tells you if you're
you know tilting left or right or going
up and up and down and a lot of times if
you don't if you're not in straight
rated and have a lot of experience at a
youth your brain is telling you that
you're straight and level and you
believe it even though the instrument
says different
see if the instrument is right yeah yeah
I focus on the instrument and realize
your mind is telling you something kind
of did you or how many near misses when
you're flying or any-any yeah flying is
turns out to be hours and hours of
complacency interrupted by little
moments of extreme terror like STD
result waiting so you are in the moment
you've had is flying because that that's
always what scares me and I don't trust
myself enough to handle stuff well you
just use half to well there's nobody
around to handle it for you you know
the very first time you solo you know my
it was like 12 hours going around the
field landing going around the field
landing at my flight instructor who was
73 years old at the time he was five
years younger than aviation itself I
figured hey this guy you know but he's
doing head he pops the door and biz goes
nice no again and you take off around at
midfield and you're very busy and stuff
you know climbing and then on the radio
you do the radio you're at midfield and
you look around the airplane and there's
nobody there it's Tonya like those
dreams you have a flying yes it's
incredible so there's a problem you know
that you have to you have to handle it
you have to fix it that's which scares
me
well I always want an adult to do things
[Laughter]
my buddy bill our buddy helicopter pilot
yeah the same thing you do like when
you're going out the first time solo you
realize like you know it all kind of you
sit the concentration is amazingly like
you're not thinking of your phone you're
not thinking of anything else that's
what's wonderful about it you you don't
think about anything else up there you
know it takes your mind off of
everything else but what you're doing we
got to wrap the show up yeah we're done
11 o'clock is our
the end of our show only 10 1102 yes the
art of more season 2 is gonna be
released on crackle tomorrow tomorrow do
you have any relationship with your
brother Randy or you yeah you do
yes they get them that's crazy what we
spent 12 years in the same bedroom
together well it's kind of like me and
Sam talking about as kids I love my
brother he's one of my five favorite
actors in the world yeah Dee and I want
to see him come back yeah that's what I
want do you think people misunderstand
the type of person he is like sometimes
people do a little off-the-wall things
and people Ike that's who that guy is
like no it's not that's not who the
person is
yeah I you know he's a great actor and I
think he still has another career I do I
bet he could yeah I mean he's well-liked
enough that he can absolutely yeah yeah
look Roman Polanski is still directing
Dennis Quaid thank you so much man thank
you it's great talking to you